vision for Africa I believe Africa will
be able to lead the world in terms of
responsible development that means both
from a social point of view and from an
environmental point of view I think
Africa is an au nique situation that we
still have massive natural resources and
we can use those in a way that will
benefit us as well as the rest of the
world that being both human and
non-human I also believe that from a
social point of view as fellow countries
that we will in the next 20 years become
a much more stable environment and the
leaders that we will elect going forward
will be based on their performance
rather than on their tribal heritage
that would be black white Indian colored
whatever travel background there come
from I'll be proud to be Africa